I love the cover - Ralph Steadman covers
which is not an artist that you
associate with like a fun cookbook and
so you're clearly staking out this is a
very different cookbook yeah I didn't
want it to look like any other cookbook
ralph steadman did all the fear loathing
books for Hunter s Thompson a huge fan
it apparently is so disturbing to to
major book selling chains that they
insisted we cover it a plain white
wrapper seriously they think this is too
scary for people to handle well it does
kind of look like you know who it's a
family cookbook but you know the Manson
Family yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah I
wanted to do something actually most of
my life professional life has been him
frankly speaking about me me me and this
is I'm a father of a nine year old girl
now and she pretty much runs the house
and all the cooking decisions so I tried
to actually make it useful cookbook this
is for her yeah for her approach I
thought it brings my hyper
organizational skills from from cooking
professionally to you know cooking at
home right and and is she an adventurous
eater because my experience with kids
are they want noodles and butter right
they don't yeah they don't want to and
and it's almost evolute like later on in
life it's an evolutionary thing to
experience more foods they'll get braver
but when they're kids they just want the
same thing over and over and over again
yeah or pizza what about your daughter
she uh she's very adventurous Lee
because I never pressure I mean I didn't
never make that mistake of honey you
should try it it's really good that
never worked for me instead I'll say you
know here's your damn noodles and butter
and you know I'm gonna eat something
really interesting here and if she
expresses anyway so say you're probably
not ready for this you know this is
grown-up stuff it's no perfect you're
not ready for a yak eyeball yet
not a lot of that at my house but but
she eats like we're all a stirs and
stuff that I never would even suggest it
to a kid I mean do you really want you
want to raise a foodie kid I mean that's
common that's kind of sick you know what
boy so nice to hear you say that I'm so
proud of my metal hunter he eats sushi
you know that's kind of wrong yeah yeah
a kid that tastes the wine and sends it
back
oh wait that's brought it for four
reasons
you